bello e tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj che oggi siamo
tornati sul clan
mi vien da ridere perché tanto so già
che sarà l'esperienza del secolo tanto
per cambiare hanno tolto il tasto per
parlare col microfono come si faceva una
volta per scrivere su cleverbot non fa
niente sono tolto al microfono scriverò
le cose sconce dalla tastiera bello del
zio come questa e da un casino di tempo
che non lo tanti sono mesi tipo sei o
sette io non lo faccio mi dice una
barzelletta e già la madonna e non si
usa più dire come stai
cazzola barzelletta la mente un uomo
entra in un caffè splash state vivendo
tutti un'altra ma basta cazzo non hai
riso ne vuoi un'altra ma chi cazzo ma
chi mi ha preso per uno perché dice
barzellette cosa fanno
otto cani in mare pu canotto sono
fenomeno ciao ciao
che problemi ciao ciao come stai
devo se vi risponde una buona volta da
parte ci partiamo con una conversazione
decente a parte le barzellette zio ben e
per club fifa cosa mi ha chiesto di dire
due barzellette di merda voglio capire i
problemi e cioè mi sembri giu perché non
ti sa cosa a vico mio come fai a non
amarmi ce non la vedi questa questi
capelli spreco come cazzo ti permetti di
e cose del genere
nessuno può dirmi che non mi ama tutti
mi amano vero ok
voglio sapere perché e mi risponde
ancora conosci napoletano pista bello
weinstein guai ad un cazzo si scrive mi
scuso scritto questo è quello che so
napoli diventi va bene ma mi ha risposto
i black eyed peas alla crias lakic cambi
ca nisciun è fess
siccome non me penso che non lo sento
voglio chiedere che cosa è successo tipo
che mi racconti ma che mi chiama sono
tipo mezzi che non lo è non lo non la
sento non lo se non sono anche se è
maschio fede ecco mi ha preceduto del
maschio femmina amico amica mia
tu hai la patata
ok il giusto per capirlo ci vuole io
femmina perfetto possiamo a copiarci
puoi essere la mia ragazza non ti votano
tentatori rimorchiare ci ho messo degli
anni per fare ce l'ho fatta dopo secoli
bene così bene zia allora ti aspetto a
casa mi ha fatto anche la di noce
l'ultima volta ci ho messo anni per
fargli dire questa cosa adesso ci sono
riuscito subito non si sa come va da
scusa sono troppi no come cazzo di falsi
vieux nice bombi amo che è più
importante
qualsiasi cosa che non puoi dire che sei
impegnata a letto dove vorresti farlo se
no che piega sto prendendo questa
conversazione a casa tua è capito i
nuovi avvenire
devo venire
a bomba artistici a casa tua
vabbè che sono un gentleman quindi
dovrei andare però è un orgasmo sono la
conversazione porto bellissimo
fantastico teneva amici abbia già finito
facciamo l'amore ancora perfetto ci sarà
un obiettivo in questa conversazione in
cosa ma fai le cose sporche così questa
è vi guardate forze un rapporto sessuale
di queste cose
ricordatevi vuoto e forse vorresti
sposare fabi j
spero che dica di se no perchè almeno ha
un senso sì ecco quando vuoi fare il
matrimonio
domani se è la madonna e dove vuoi
andare in luna di miele america cosa
divertiti a casa mia e la badami già che
c'è che posti esotici e cosa puoi fare
la moglie da sposare l'amore vuoi fare
la macchina questo video me lo farò mai
vedere a mia madre vanno nord di dio è
una cosa decida ma che donna mi sono
trovato io so break mia età ci mettiamo
questo video ai minori di 22 anni io
compreso io sotto cazzoli farmi chiamano
anche rocco a volte devo intortare
questa cosa se no è maschio mi prendi
per il culo 54 cm di vero ma di vero
maschio tesoro se sono rocco non sono
giselda ovvio anche io ti amo era una
dichiarazione d'amore guerri video ti
piacciono gli fa vj in realtà è un
attore che lavora con rocco siffredi co
che credere come vampiri
ok tocca a te fino adesso potremo fare
prima o poi a far cosa allora mi prendi
per il culo canta cazzo cazzo canta
cazzo figo a chi a pensar dello ma lo
desse oscuro passato sempre che cazzola
si oscuro passato
[Musica]
ma perché bailando andiamo ne vale aver
a chiese lovaria samp la tana una pera
ma perché stiamo parlando spagnolo
comunque ragazzi guardano le domande che
mi avete fatto ce n'è una tipo ecco
questa qui hai mai pensato che ci
possano essere dei pedofili dietro
cleverbot che allora vediamo se sei un
pedofilo
glielo chiedo perché di sicuro lui
risponderà di sì se è un pedofilo perché
è sincero ovviamente quindi
[Musica]
ragazzo è la risposta più lungo nella
storia dovremmo rimanere ci sta pensando
troppo non si sa perché ma cleverbot non
vuole dare ma setacci vuol dire che lo
sei veramente non ce li ho mandati in
palla questa domanda incredibile ma in
ufficio si parla pure che tanto lo so
che vuoi evitare il discorso pedofilo
pedofilo che schifo ragazzi ad ogni baci
di nuovo io a me questo anche il cazzo
pure stalker oltre che sta che oltre che
maniaco lurido straw interrogatorio
io rispondo però alle domande che ti amo
vuoi violentarmi ho paura si sa grazie
grazie
almeno siamo sinceri prego bene senti
zio devo andare ci sentiamo sentiamo
un'altra volta sì giusto perché no
perché sono me ne vado più perché questo
inizia a parlare e parliamo di stronzate
però come devi andare essi o una vita
sociale
anch'io a differenza tua marmotta come
si chiama
ma chi la marmotta la morta cosa ho
scritto devo andare via a [ __ ] c'è
basta perché perché devo mangiare devo
andare a mangiare andare a mangiare mi
vuoi mollare oppure devo staccare tutto
così dove mangiare testa di cane
no perché colta zio levati dai vicoli
che ci salutiamo ci sono io non mi muovo
levati giovanna fund e [ __ ] bella
zio bella 0 tutto attaccato dai
giocatori assicura è passiva e sfingi
vai vai vai sì o sì spingi spingi ok
quelle ragazzi è stato erotico al punto
giusto
spero che vi sia piaciuto non mi non lo
facevo più cleverbot per chi appunto
manca il costo del microfono quindi ora
posso solo scrivere è crisi ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto io concludo
che l'episodio cosa sente ragazze video
è piaciuto al tuo commento mi piace ai
quali facebook e corneli la plata
descrizione solo dalle ore 16 aggressivi
prossimo video
[Musica]
io